[Music]
in this video we will showcase to you
the 10 best tyrannosaurus rex's that
have appeared in movie screens of course
there have been many of these
incarnations of the tyrant lizard king
but we won't be including the ones that
appeared in low budget flicks
but only the ones from movies that have
a good rating and we will also include
the ones that are slight variations
and advanced versions of this dinosaur
but before we go into the list do check
out our mind qt spring store as we have
quite a number of merch
that are up for grabs and while you're
at it do remember to smash that
notification bell for regular updates
so here goes the list number one
rexy from jurassic park let's start with
the famous
the most famous rexy she is a female
tyrannosaurus rex that appears in
jurassic world
and is also one of the oldest dinosaurs
to live in jurassic park
new blur wrecks or tyrannosaur nublar is
the name being given to her officially
and she was the queen of the island rexy
the largest of the tyrannosaurus rex has
seen in the series
she was 44 feet long and 17 feet tall
rexy is known to have impressive
strength and is very experienced in
combat and surviving
she was able to take on two raptors and
was able to survive on island nublar
for nine years prior to being captured
in jurassic world
she was also the one that battled the
indominus rex and won the battle with
the help of blue the raptor
and the mussosaurus number two grimlock
from transformers
this next one is a transformer and has
the beast mode on
as the tyrannosaurus rex and we have
taken this one from the michael bay
movies
as one of the most powerful transformer
warriors alive his general approach to a
problem is to smash it first
worry about the specifics later in
transformers age of extinction grimlock
and the dinobots
are captured by lockdown as trophies
referred to as legendary knights
this t-rex version can also breathe an
extremely hot fire
from his mouth that can melt and destroy
other transformers
he is also the largest known t-rex to
appear in movies as he was easily over
45 meters
or 150 feet long as the dinosaur mode
number three the vastutosaurus rex from
king kong
this large unique tyrannosaurus from
skull island was a direct descendant
from the t-rex it measures 40-50 feet
long
and has the biggest terrestrial predator
on skull island the v-rex like their
prehistoric
cousins the tyrannosaurus have little
competition for their spot as top
predators
in spite of their size they can turn
into a surprising burst of speed for
short periods of time clocking up to 25
miles per hour for limited stretches
in pursuit of prey v-rex's have
developed many unique features
over the 66 million years since the
mesozoic era like a more robust head
extra thick height that looks more like
crocodilians their teeth are jagged and
their bloodlust is taken to the extreme
number four the momma dino from ice age
taken from an animated flick this next
entry is at first appearing to be
the villain of ice age 3 and she
kidnapped sith the sloth
to rescue her babies however later on
near the end
moment dino saves sid and the others by
knocking off rudy another large dinosaur
off a cliff
it is unclear how momma and her kind got
down to the secret world under the ice
but towards the end of the film she and
her kids go somewhere in the underground
world and she gives
sit a lick as she will miss him she is
larger than the largest known
tyrannosauruses found and she was around
40-50 feet long
she normally speaks a language that is
spoken by growling roaring
and grunting like a regular animal
number five
one eye from speckles one eye is the red
tyrannosaurus rex who is the main
antagonist in the film the dino king
and he is mainly speckle's arch rival
when he grows although speckles was a
darbosaurus
a closely related species to the
tyrannosaurus so one eye
is a red t-rex that has a visible scar
on his body
and also having a huge stretch mark on
his left eye he also has
a few misplaced teeth his upper body has
a reddish coloration but most of his
body is white or greenish in color
he is shown being ruthless and uncaring
to anything he sees
he will also kill anything without
hesitation nor showing any sign of mercy
as for his size he was bigger than a
darbosaurus at more than 40 feet long
number six grumpy from the land of the
lost grumpy is a tyrannosaurus rex who
appears as one of the main villains in
the 1974
tv series land of the lost and later as
the secondary antagonist in the 2009
comedy movie
of the same name in this list we will
look at the 2009 version of the dinosaur
unlike the majority of hungry predators
in fiction as well as his previous
incarnations
grumpy has a mostly complex personality
although
at first his only goal was to simply eat
the protagonist he later developed a
vendetta against the rick
for insulting him and also attempted to
prove his intelligence to him
he didn't want to kill rick for
sustenance but only for revenge
but later befriended him after eating
him and pooping him
out number 7 the t-rex from king kong
this tyrannosaurus rex stood at 3.66
meters or 12 feet tall at the hips
and measured 12.3 meters or 40 feet in
length and weighed up to 10 tons
it was the biggest known meat eater of
skull island in the 1933 king kong movie
the t-rex was modeled after charles our
knight's depiction of the tyrannosaurus
and as such there is some confusion
however as to the name of this dinosaur
as it possesses three fingers per hand
unlike the real tyrannosaurus which had
only two so
in the movie this dinosaur was a vicious
predator who was about to attack
and arrow and then kong then arrived to
fend off the creature and battle for
quite a while
until kong snapped its jaw killing it
number eight guangi from the valley of
guangyi another one of the earlier
representations of upright dinosaurs the
t-rex guangi
is the titular character and main
antagonist in the 1969 classic
the valley of guangi he is described as
a male tyrannosaurus rex
his body has a blue colored skin covered
in scales and bumps
guangi stood probably somewhere between
20-30 feet long and closely resembles an
allosaurus
from the 1 million years bc and was
originally intended to be won
but later dubbed as a t-rex it was a
creature of legend and this t-rex guangi
lived in a hidden valley
in the middle of the country of mexico
it was killed in the movie
burning to death slowly and painfully
number nine the nazi rex from iron sky
2.
yeah we also have a dictator that writes
a theropod dinosaur on this list
in iron sky the coming race adolf hitler
settles and rides a t-rex on the moon
the dinosaur appears to be breaking down
a metal door and proceeds to eat people
while being
immune to small arms fire the year is
2047
and 29 years later after the nuclear war
that immediately followed the battle
between the earth and the moon nazis
rendering the planet inhospitable
so the real antagonists were a race of
reptilians that arrived on earth
during the age of the dinosaurs and
continue to live in the center of the
earth
and after a brief skirmish there the
dreaded nazi leader comes back to the
moon riding his nazi wrecks in full
glory
and number 10 alien wrecks from planet
of dinosaurs
lastly we have the alien rex which is
the main antagonist
of the 1977 science fiction film planet
of dinosaurs
he is an extraterrestrial dinosaur
living on a planet where the inhabitants
evolved to resemble prehistoric
dinosaurs from earth
through convergent evolution in the
movie he first appeared walking behind a
hill
in front of the humans and they run off
and the tyrannosaurus is seen fighting
ostegosaurus and later kills him after a
brief
fight this dinosaur like the earlier
models was upright in stature
and the tail was seen being dragged on
the ground his skin
was bumpy and the alien t-rex was a
vicious cunning greedy and a very
determined animal
and so with that we end our list of the
10 best tyrannosaurus from movies
do tell us what you think about it and
whether there are other movie dinosaurs
you would want us to make a list of
do like share and subscribe for more
videos of this kind and others being
monsters and kaiju related contents